[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute mache ich eine spargelcremesuppe
wie schon angekündigt und dafür habe ich
hier schon suppen spargelsuppe spargel
ist einfach ein etwas zarter spargel
etwas dünner und das besondere daran ist
ihr müsst wirklich mit den unteren teil
weg stellen denn hier oben ist ja gar
nicht hart und zählen man kann den
einfach wirklich wunderbar mit essen
ich habe dir jetzt auch schon geschält
und habe auch noch von unserem
spargelessen von gestern schale übrig
und die nehme ich jetzt dies schon
gewaschen und wetzel jetzt gleich im
wasser kochen damit ich einfach den
vollen spargel geschmack habe also
soviel dazu ich brauche eben diese
spargel schale und dann habe ich hier
noch restliche zutaten für die suppe
dafür nehme ich etwas butter und mehl
für die mehlschwitze hier habe ich
suppen spargel etwas zucker sahne eine
zitrone zum abschmecken salz und pfeffer
hier gebe ich jetzt schon mal den
spargel schale ins wasser ist auch das
wasser was ich später zum kochen der
suppe benutze den dass hier etwa 5
minuten kochen so habe ich den spargel
geschmack einfach schon mal im wasser
mit dabei ich gebe dir noch einen deckel
drauf perfekt ich kenne zwar die
mehlschwitze machen und die butter in
einem separaten topf erwärmen
das ist der topf in dem ich gleich die
suppe mache und ich habe jetzt hier auf
mittel hohe hitze gestellt dass die
butter einfach nicht so schnell heiß
wird umspritzt wenn ihr mit gusseisernen
koch dann solltet ihr allgemein beachten
dass er etwas gefühlvoller kochen müsst
also wenn ihr da auf zu hohe hitze geht
brennt euch alles an weil einfach der
top die temperatur perfekt speichert
zunächst regen hitze ist aber auch nicht
immer gut daher einfach gefühlt weil ich
habe das jetzt hier auf wie gesagt auf
mittel hoher hitze auf stufe 6 von 9
was ist schön langsam schmelzen
jetzt kann ich ja das mehl dazugeben und
einfach langsam anschwitzen bis es eine
hellbraune schöne farbe bekommt hier
nehme ich jetzt etwas eine höhere stufe
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich mich
auch schon mal um den spargel kümmern
da werde ich jetzt nämlich zu machen
dass ich den spargel kopf getrennt
abschneide und restlichen stücke einfach
hin etwas so drei bis vier zentimeter
stücke schneiden
[Musik]
die spargelköpfe sind immer etwas
schneller gar deswegen will ich jetzt
nicht dass jetzt herrschen also beweist
die jetzt separat auf und der restliche
spargel kommt hier in der schüssel
[Musik]
den spargel sich jetzt hier noch kurz ab
und kann jetzt hier schon mal
löffelweise den zug zum mehlschwitze
dazu geben
schön rühren damit das kleine keine
klümpchen bilden
[Musik]
und jetzt schön wieder aufkochen lassen
da kann ich jetzt direkt etwas zucker
dazugeben
das salz und pfeffer
freundin sally konz und so werde ich
konzentrier dich nicht die köpfe zum
recht nicht die köpfe zum recht und dann
lange was machte schüttet die
spargelköpfe
ja wenn man die arbeit vorher macht und
sich darauf konzentriert schaut man
nicht durcheinander
ich lasse die suppe kurz etwa 5 minuten
kochen
dann kommt der spargel dazu also dieser
teil hier und suppen spargel braucht
noch nicht so lange im etwa 15 minuten
das heißt dann habe ich insgesamt eine
kochzeit von zehn minuten und dann gebe
ich gleich noch die köpfe dazu arbeit
warte ich erst mal was so vor sich hin
köcheln und genießen das schöne wetter
so noch nur ein lager zu machen
glauben wir machen noch einmal kurz auf
nur noch gut aus
also hier gebe ich jetzt die starken
stücke mit rein lasst sie etwa 5 minuten
kochen und ich schmecke jetzt auch
direkt schon die super mit zitronensaft
ab also ich mag spargelcremesuppe immer
gerne mache drohne ich mach mal noch ein
bisschen
ich kann ja noch nachsitzen
das behalte ich so zurück die darf
wieder weiterkochen und hier kann ich
jetzt schon mal die croutons machen
ich habe hier einfach drei laugenstangen
von gestern noch übrig die sind schon
ziemlich trocken wie man sieht die
schneide ich jetzt in würfel
theoretisch kann ich schon ein paar in
die pfanne geben
ihr könnt euch den schlüssel auch sparen
ich dachte mir ich krieg nicht alle auf
einmal rein da habe ich schon olivenöl
drin mit butter schmeckt auch gut
buttercroissants und dann habe ich hier
noch knoblauch den schneide ich einfach
in kleine scheiben der kommt noch rein
dann eigentlich nur noch salz und verrat
so lieben wir unsere kultur und ihr
könnt die auch so vermischen mit dem öl
oder mit der flüssigen butter und auf
dem backblech geben sich deswegen
deswegen wurde ich zwei schlüsseln und
auf dem backblech geben und dann im ofen
backen oder halt kurz in der pfanne
aber ich brauche noch so papa
[Musik]
ich hab jetzt hier ein paar spargel
enden raus die will ich nämlich nicht
mit pürieren
und den rest werde ich jetzt kurz im
topf für ihren
jetzt schon sehen ich so mache es auch
bei kartoffelsuppe einen teil mit bryn
endlich kann ich hier die spargelköpfe
dazugeben den restlichen spargel dazu
geben noch mal ganz kurz kochen lassen
und dann muss ich es eigentlich nur mit
der sahne abschlag und fertig
spargelcremesuppe 90° spargelcremesuppe
100 ich sagte dass ich sage es bei jedem
suchen wie du eigentlich dass eine suppe
nie so nah so fern wird alles hat nichts
mit motiven zu tun allein gestellt das
ist auch so oder weiß nicht so vieles
was wichtig ist und glaubt mir wenn ihr
mehr suppenessen würde dann würde dir
vielleicht auch nicht so zunehmend zu
nehmen ja ich könnte etwas aufzufassen
ist mir gerade eingefallen weil das die
suppe ist ein tolles ding also da ist es
günstig natürlich eine suppe ist günstig
außer man wird halt irgendwelche
morcheln reingeht mutter oder soja oder
fledermäuse was machen wir machen ja nur
ich genau deswegen ist es wirklich
günstiges rezept essen ich habe es total
tut mir leid ich habe sogar die spargel
schale genau höher ist öfters so ganz
wichtig und teilt dieses video mein gott
ich weiß es nicht in den harry potter
oder was weiß ich stelle keinen
flughafen gebaut aber teile dieses video
das mehr menschen so menschlich machen
wird wer aber dann schneller fertig als
berlin ja solches ja damit zu erlangen
also ich probiere hier ab trotzdem
kosten kohlereste wette also der erste
spargel wasserstoff erweiterung aber so
genial wenn es keine tüten zu bist du
hast richtig cool ist nein spaß so gut
weil bei uns ist muss so morgens immer
fürs ganze team brezel mit oder gibt es
irgendwelche leute es nicht essen
denn die jungs essen-werden laugenbrezel
wir mädels nicht denn
werden davon schnell wieder hungrig also
machen wir meldet immer gesund lied für
alle und unser part ist dann praktisch
kartons fürs mittagessen oder und was
will ich mir ging ja oder ja cool ich
suppe ich nur die summe noch wallander
dann kriegst du leider nicht das
roastbeef was ich gerade rosa gebraten
habe mit kartoffeln aus dem ofen holen
und stimmig mit solchen tag was will ich
mehr also nimm du deine suppe macht die
so viel glamour und ich wünsche euch
viel spaß beim nachmachen bis zum
nächsten mal tipps ich träume seit
tagesprogramm ja wie das nahtlos wie es
für dich wieder schließlich tragen seit
tagen von wiener schnitzel ohne spaß
jetzt ohne schusswaffe
[Musik]